uh I I only had one experience in St
Louis
I went out there in like 2011 maybe
maybe 20 yeah it was 2011. I went out
there
there's a radio station out there that
tried to hire me uh a guy named Boogie D
was out there I turned the job down but
um
that night I ended up uh Freddie Gibbs
9th Wonder and Rhapsody had a show
that LRG sponsored and it was not a
popping show it was kind of it was kind
of whatever but after that me and Fred
went to East St Louis and we went to a
place called the pink slip he wasn't a
slip yes
he was in a slip they had you with a
pink slip yeah that's what's up you have
fun I had a great time yeah is that is
that uh have you been to the pink flip
yeah I want anything to slip open no
more is it closed yeah I'm about to slip
in the line man that's some old school
[ __ ] I ain't did that in a minute but I
ain't lived in St Louis in a while too
but [ __ ] that's some you you was in you
was on some St Louis ship but East St
Louis different State Illinois correct
for people who don't know East St Louis
is in Illinois yeah that's Illinois
and they're St Louis in St Louis is St
Louis U.S cycle we don't claim Missouri
St Louis USA then it's East St Louis
Illinois you don't claim Missouri yeah
that's a real estate we're a blue City I
guess or something like that but we
don't really be [ __ ] with the whole
Missouri wave that [ __ ] real racism
[ __ ] up out there bro straight up I've
heard yeah Missouri terrible I mean it's
it's like a swing state so there's like
all all sides of the coin there right
like you said like the St Louis is
probably a blue City it's definitely a
swing States for a reason yeah St Louis
we're out of black people Kansas City
too like a lot of you know I'm saying St
Louis County city but [ __ ] even more
south St Louis shot my KC [ __ ] though
how far is Casey from uh St Louis a
couple hours just a little drive like
when you're growing up right obviously
St Louis has had a successful rap scene
shout out to Natalie Shadow the St Louis
X Chingy Jake Juan been going on
um and then like obviously Kansas City
has like Tech N9 and the Strange Music
[ __ ] going on yeah I'll influence for
you by just all that [ __ ] in general I
was influenced by the lunatics and
nearly on some how to rip St Louis you
know what I'm saying and uh
I think I was influenced by my city in
the same way nearly was like where I'm
from it's like some Soulful [ __ ] like
our parents listen to like a whole bunch
of like old Soulful [ __ ] like we all
grow up in church if you from the hood
you you was going to church when you was
by church or it was some people but from
church people around you so you feel me
all that [ __ ] kind of just inspired all
that singing [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying that bluesy [ __ ] you know yeah I
think Nelly uh successfully probably did
like real melody in hip-hop before most
people that [ __ ] was like probably
before everybody doing this your son now
yeah the drugs down that's like one of
the hardest nelly songs ever bro yeah
they're loving me bro oh God and free
city was an underrated album yeah free
City hard too shout out to Murphy Lee
man shout out to the whole uh who else
was from shout out to Murph Dirty Man
real [ __ ] he vegan too he's vegan are
you vegan oh yeah good for you and uh I
couldn't do it man yeah I think you
vegan [ __ ] he look vegan nowadays